mount sinai new york an upper middle
class town on the north shore of long
island
inhabited by the working class
and city commuters
with no shortage of trendy eateries
and then there's the handlebar hello
handlebar how can i help you bill leroy
a former construction worker and his
wife carolyn bought the handlebar just
one year ago
oh boy the handlebars was a really nice
place and when i saw it was for sale i
jumped on it and our specials menu when
we came into the handlebar we saw that
it had been run down
but billy being so handsy
now they're on we saw the potential of
having a great place
in its heyday this was the place to be
this was the place that the judges came
this was the place that the lawyers came
the doctors came
now it's not like that anymore
the nightmare began when 70 of the money
was coming from the bar and almost
nothing was coming from the dining room
when you can't turn 18 tables on a
friday or a saturday night you're in a
lot of trouble
bill is an okay manager can i bother you
to make me a cup of coffee billy usually
stays at the bar but being an owner he
has to be more involved
like answer the phone somebody on the
phone sometimes he can be very grouchy
now go put all the stuff back where you
got it then
like his mood swings change i've had it
with these people
[Music]
this place is gross like dirt filth that
had been built up over the past 20 years
the interior it looks dated
the decor
[Music]
i think it's great
the core menu is basically the same as i
inherited with the restaurant they look
disgusting i don't know why anybody
orders them melissa is an excellent chef
i'm not a chef i don't claim to be a
chef i don't want to be a chef i
not very creative
five minutes
the food is
crap
i think hiring me wasn't necessarily the
best idea i don't really know what i'm
doing here i don't intend for it to be
my career
i really don't think melissa has any
weaknesses as a cook
the day we call it quits is the day we
have not one penny to put into this
place
we took out an equity line of credit
that's almost maxed out and drains our
savings account god help us
if the handlebar fails we'd risk losing
our house
then i never want to lose my house we
need to worry about you and me in the
handlebar bottom line
if chef ramsay doesn't come here our
time is very limited
i definitely don't think it's another
year
[Music]
chef gordon ramsay is on a mission to
turn the handlebar around
west left west right
except he has one small problem
handlebar i'm lost um what if you could
help me okay i'm right on the fork but
do i go left do i go right because they
both say west okay so you're gonna bear
to the right
right and there's gonna be like a big
shopping center right after it okay
there it is there handlebar
there's gordon ramsay how do you know
because i just talked to him on the
phone get out of here yeah really yeah
handlebar
finally now we're in mount sinai just
outside new york
mount sinai sounds a little bit like
cyanide i hope it doesn't taste like it
i'm a little nervous to meet chef ramsey
i'm carolyn
the man is an expert at what he does the
man is a a well-renowned chef
b
owns beautiful restaurants because i've
seen them on the internet whatever you
like
you don't get that way because you're an
idiot all right
hello
gordon ramsay's like really hot he has
like a nice body and stuff like for an
older man he's very very hot i didn't
want to serve him because i just talk
and i just don't stop talking so i was
nervous if i said something stupid that
i just wouldn't stop and i would just
keep talking and talking and talking
this is our dinner menu right we also
have our price fix menu all right
and the early bird specials okay great
we'll have a quick look thank you
one menu two menu three menu full menu
right
definitely quantity
let's hope it's quality i need to
continue to cook this because i [ __ ]
it up
pizza fondue filet mignon
are you ready yet i'll go for the soup
of the day
i'll go for the seafood crepe as well
and then i'm going to finish with the
filet mignon fondue filet mignon please
thank you no problem excellent
that's nice and busy
dining room's empty
look at the place the decor is ghastly
it's so 80s even the fish tank's been
here longer than me
gosh
[Music]
i think chef ramsay came close to
ordering the worst things but you know
everything that's here was pretty much
crap food
yeah thank you no problem
new
when chef ramsay was sitting there i was
just praying that he was going to be
happy with everything
phil
let me see if i could find him thank you
great first thoughts that went through
my head was oh my god
and just like to say that that's uh
nicely seasoned um very tasty and
perfect for winter's day
i'm glad you enjoyed it nice melissa
does a nice job
grabs
i'll check on the rest of your food
thank you very much
he said your soup was fabulous really
yes he loved it i think melissa's a
great cook i think she's very creative i
think melissa underestimates herself a
lot i thought it came out pretty shitty
this time
there's crab in there there's lobster
and some shrimp in there also thank you
no problem
oh yeah yeah
chef ramsay seems to have a uh habit to
take his food apart before he eats it
so i'm looking forward to hearing what
he has to say
how is everything
robbery and the scallops are
firm
the prawns are way overcooked
and the crab meat
it's plastic it's imitation crab meat
yeah if you told me his imitation
craving me i wouldn't have ordered it
oh god help me
well
that was a disaster seafood crepe
yeah
that's seafood crap
this is the worst of it i'm sure
i'm waiting on my beef fondue filet
mignon fondue which is raw so
why am i waiting so long there's the
steak
and this is the oil
thank you no problem nothing like
waiting to cook your meat is there all
right put that in
[Music]
time
for a little prayer
[Music]
comes out looking like dog food
he splits it out
that was rancid pointless tasteless a
complete utter joke
i'm gonna cry
why would you deep fry a filet mignon
one of the country's best steaks deep
fried
are they stupid
oh no
[Music]
i wanted him to be happy with us but i
kind of knew deep down inside that there
has to be something wrong with the
restaurant otherwise he wouldn't be here
oh my god what a disaster disaster yeah
no it's not
after an underwhelming first meal
okay pull together gordon realizes that
the owners and the chef are oblivious to
the restaurant's real problems what's
wrong with the business
it's this room as you see it we can't
fill 18 tables on a friday night
that's the problem
no the problem here is the food
the food's bad bill
i never really had complaints about the
food so that was never really an area of
concern to me when the fondue arrived i
mean that's just a joke i don't enjoy
the fondue either but you're the chef
aren't you you're the one that's yeah
you're
you're running it as the head chef right
that that's the intent so
change it i don't know
what to do about it have you lost your
passion
i never had a passion to begin with
i don't want to be a chef
i was really shocked that that's the way
she felt so you're not a chef no
i had applications for the job here as a
chef when she approached me and said
would you give me the opportunity i mean
you don't ask for that opportunity if
you don't care what you're doing why did
you take the job melissa if you're not a
chef the other guy was going out that
was here
okay um
i didn't think our situation was as bad
as i'm finding out minute by minute
having exposed melissa's apathy in the
kitchen
gordon observes a dinner service to find
out how her attitude is affecting the
food
[Music]
i know he was here to help but it's
still very nerve-wracking having someone
of his stature standing there staring at
you
what they do
mushrooms
is that how that goes out like that yes
holy crap
[Music]
stuff mushrooms
[Music]
those mushrooms look sadder than a
customer
jordan said they're very sad mushrooms
why
why just now actually that's a recipe of
my own i made it myself i was very
disappointed that it wasn't presented to
him the right one people eat them [ __ ]
for you what's my choice potato rice
vegetables baked potato mashed potato
french fries rice with veggies we use
half instant half with mashed potatoes
why do they mix the powdered mashed
potatoes with fresh mashed potatoes
that's a way of reusing the baked
potatoes so you don't even actually make
fresh mashed potatoes no
no
do you want mashed potato baked potato
french fries rice or vegetables
that's bad
a little more done than usual but other
than that yeah
[Music]
just an hour into dinner service and the
restaurant has run out of basic
vegetables we ran out of broccoli
cauliflower yeah and replaced them with
an unusual substitute
yes wow you've never heard of that
before
how are you radishes honestly gordon of
course not something i would you know
expect with my steak you want some veg
right yeah you know is there anything to
keep him happy have we checked with
melissa i i want to eat the radishes
either so customers are complaining
about no vegetables
any broccoli vegetable carrots or
cabbage veg
veg oh stop
there's stalks uh yeah that's a frozen
bag that's why it's crap
even though melissa is managing to keep
up with the orders
the customers are still not satisfied i
don't like it at all this is unusual
it's not real
and gordon needs billy to finally
understand that the food is handlebar's
biggest problem billy customers are
complaining about the food
[Music]
you can't walk around oblivious the fact
that you think this is good
yeah but it's not bad in everybody's
opinion
you can't take care of everybody's taste
buds something that some people like
other people aren't going to like that
at all no one's got any
control
and
basics here that have just gone
completely [ __ ] wrong
if you accept it everybody else has
accepted it
and truthfully you've accepted it
oh absolutely not i was kind of really
disappointed i knew we needed help i
didn't think we were that bad
i was quite skeptical about his
intentions
whatever
really starting to dislike him
after witnessing last night's pathetic
dinner service gordon comes in early for
a kitchen inspection
what a mess
nothing labelled
porsche's taken out that's dreadful
broccoli
last night we ran out of vegetables
because the chef can't be bothered to
cook fresh broccoli
the reminiscence of exxon valdez
oh my god when was the last time the
back of the fridge was clean you look at
it
what is that in there
oh my god almighty
that there was a clam
oh what a mess
the state of the fridge
has only confirmed gordon's belief that
the restaurant lacks true passion and
leadership so you're in charge of the
kitchen and the general hygiene yeah
supposed to be yes
why is it in a mess
um
it's 100 times cleaner than it was six
months ago sure it was
okay when was the last time you had a
little wipe down there or
uh in here
just just even that i've never done my
god
unbelievable
oh
this
is embarrassing
that she usually does clean that right
okay i'm glad you're starting to make
excuses for it no
if you thought this was bad
have a look at this
chef ramsay seemed to feel that i was
making excuses for everything and really
had no idea of the past practices that
had gone on here
okay last night we served frozen
vegetables to a customer and we've got
two boxes of broccoli there you know i
can do it all that's it you were happy
to serve frozen broccoli
over fresh broccoli i'm trying to open
up your eyes billy and explain to you
you know what the current situation is
when was the last time this fridge was
cleaned a week ago
oh come on this hasn't been cleaned in
years
no
no no it hasn't i'm sorry 21 years in
the business i'll bet every [ __ ]
dollar i have this [ __ ] place hasn't
been cleaned in years
i'm disgusted put your hand down there
he still never did bend down and touch
it it was a big thing of denial for him
i'll take responsibility for the fact
that i haven't changed it but it's not
all my fault you know
everything's coming out and this place
is going to get cleaned i wish you'd
give me a little more credit for
cleaning it up as much as i had so far
it looks 60 70 times better than it used
to look in here philly that's
disgusting no it's it's not fine we got
a big problem when was the last time
that fridge was steam cleaned i had the
kid in there doing it last week did you
check what he'd done
no obviously not
so why can't you like a man and do
something about it nope
my god
i just don't even know what to say
anymore
he just keeps tearing apart everything
that wasn't done and not giving me
credit or
pat on the back to things that were done
un [ __ ] believable so that just
proves and confirms how weak this guy is
he's not running this place this place
is running at him and is in need of a
[ __ ] serious clean
that is appalling
prompted by gordon's shocking discovery
melissa enlists the wait staff to do a
thorough cleaning what do you use to
clean the solution
it's
disgusting
i really wish i had a mask on me right
now
philly
just two seconds in
[Music]
i was hoping he was gonna tell me i
understand billy that this isn't your
fault but it really needs to be taken
care of so let's take care of it
i'm [ __ ] pissed off
and i'm upset on the kind of [ __ ] that
i've just discovered in there time to
drag me through the mud some more it is
what it is
you don't see one [ __ ] ounce bothered
about it billy you can't just stick your
head back in the sand ignore it billy
sure you can
what do you want me to do flip out and
yell and scream like you do that's not
my way the responsibility is yours billy
i guess you want something done right i
guess you have to do it yourself i just
get rid of everybody in the restaurant
i'll do it all myself great idea and
then when it doesn't work out and then
when i drop dead because i [ __ ] sleep
two hours a day then maybe it'll get
done or maybe who cares once you're dead
it doesn't make a difference anymore oh
come on
now i feel you're copping out of me now
because now i'm just getting dragged
through the mud
you're a weak man billy
i really i'm glad you had enough
i was not gonna be ridiculed just for
the sake of needing his help
finished can you please talk to me no
billy can you talk to me please no
i have nothing to say billy
i wouldn't talk to my dog the way you
talk to me go [ __ ] yourself that's right
the hell with everything i'll make it
work myself without his help everything
in my life that i've ever set out to do
i did on my own
finished
[Music]
i'm done
what a week man
philly
[Music]
unable to accept gordon's criticism
billy decides he's had enough
[ __ ] him [ __ ] him [ __ ] them
the fridge is disgusting i've asked her
to be cleaned he's telling me i'm
dragging him through the mud
and he [ __ ] walks out
he's mad right now and he's being
stubborn
right now he's too extreme to admit it i
just want him to act responsible while
gordon tries to make sense of billy's
actions he doesn't have to act like a
baby billy rehearses a speech to gordon
i am so done
connect me on i had nothing to say to
you
not a word
there was nothing in my head
that made me want to think and
reconsider about doing this
can you go out there and just you know
have a word of them you guys are the
backbone of this place you can't just
throw the towel in i knew billy would
get mad done she's [ __ ] done with all
this supposed but honestly you don't
face the truth you can't do anything
about it we've been busting our ass
trying to help you out you're giving up
on yourself this place and us i wouldn't
talk to my dog the way that jackass
talks to me i'm done
he's telling you the truth though billy
great there's ways to go about it 46
years old never been talked to like that
by anybody and you know what the only
thing that's keeping me from [ __ ]
hitting him with a [ __ ] baseball bat
is that i'd go to [ __ ] jail for it
i'm done
done done
finished
and you're not the man everyone here
thought you were billy absolutely not
you're gonna give up and you're gonna
give up on all of us fine be a [ __ ]
baby billy [ __ ] it i'm done
yeah you know what put the place up for
[ __ ] sale i can go back to
construction and enjoy my [ __ ] life
the way i used to before all of this
[ __ ]
we'll go to bankruptcy court and just
give it all up [ __ ] it i'm done bye
so help me god i will not open the door
tomorrow you can all go [ __ ] yourselves
and i don't care if it's all for nothing
do not care
billy you know what i'll survive somehow
vinny [ __ ] you
unbelievable
having just missed her chance to defuse
the situation carolyn now faces the
prospect of running the handlebar alone
very upset
i have a husband that's ready to throw
in the towel so here i am stuck holding
the bag
let me help you
i want you to help me but i don't know
what to do i have a job that i have to
work so i can pay my mortgage okay
i don't know what to do
why can't we
work at turning this around
i would love to work or turn this around
okay
let me open the restaurant tonight okay
okay
i'm feeling that i'm gonna do what i
have to do
to make everything work
because i'm not walking out now and i'm
not flushing the last 17 years of my
life down the bowl to further inspire
carolyn to move forward with the plan
gordon shows her the dedication of her
staff what a difference
it's looking great
huh
you've done a great job we were clean to
walk in we were more or less just doing
it to just show that like we are
dedicated and we do want this to work
billy's gone whether he comes back later
or not it's not gonna affect what we're
doing tonight we're opening and we're
opening with a clean fridge healthy
attitude we're hungry to get this place
full yes
let's go
her courage now bolstered by her staff's
support carolyn leaves billy a message
billy
i'm not going to stop now i will do
whatever it takes to make my restaurant
succeed with chef ramsay's help
i'll succeed
i just told him my determination that
i'm going forward with this regardless
if he wanted to or not
the restaurant is about to open for
dinner but to get the handlebar moving
in the right direction gordon makes some
quick additions to the menu melissa
let's do a special tonight some fried
clams with a homemade tata sauce it
switched lambs chef ramsay he's one of
the best chefs in the world you know
standing right next to me and was uh
very surreal
generously season them with a flower
straight in
edge of the fire
and then again a nice little season
there okay
yeah minute the customer rides the table
they sit down and we need to give them
fresh hand-cut
homemade potato chips a warm welcome mmm
no those are good this place is more
laid back so i think the chips are a
good idea it's different awesome
[Music]
hi good evening do you have a
reservation
[Music]
i thought it was great that chef ramsay
could show us how to make such a simple
thing like potato chips that
everybody would love
we do have a special appetizer today
deep fried clams with a homemade tartar
sauce all right we'll do that yeah
potato chips are done well special is
going well keep it going yeah nice
atmosphere in the dining room really
good clams there we are clams everyday
love the clams
they said that's the best thing that
they've ever had here so it's going
really good we're not serving dirty
bowls to the table let's go melb yeah
[Music]
i didn't think he was going to come back
i was really really surprised that he
came back so quickly i am angry about
things that transpired earlier in the
day still
[Music]
hours after threatening to sell the
business owner billy returns to the
handlebar just in time for dinner
service
there was absolutely no part of me that
still wanted chef ramsey to be here i
wanted him to be gone
billy come on let go of it
when billy came back he had his bad
attitude of yeah whatever
billy
please
i love you
that's all that matters
that's all that matters
i can honestly say that i love my wife
more than anything in this world so i
came back here from my wife
while billy tries to reconnect with his
restaurant i need my food melissa
struggles to give the wait staff
complete orders i ran half the [ __ ]
order i need the rest of it there's a
lot of problems who's this for here
melissa that's been here in 37 minutes i
don't know
the creeps i forgot half of it so
melissa just stopped communicating i
mean that's just how melissa is and i
think that's when we ran into problems
are any of my foods coming out for any
of my tables i have no
idea communication is the one thing and
it's not happening right now oh boy and
i was you know in the weeds so much i
really couldn't tell who was waiting and
who was wanting i need salmon pony area
was the salmon on that i think melissa
got very flustered back there this place
was total chaos it's nine o'clock i've
been here since what time
5 30.
i just don't know what to say with the
orders backed up in the kitchen killing
killing whatever god help us
impatient hungry customers begin taking
out their frustrations
on each other you know what you're
talking about before you open up your
mouth i don't open up my mouth any time
you can do whatever have you please stop
talking to my parents this
way that's ridiculous it's a total
disaster and uh i really think i'm to
the point now that i don't know what
else to do come on billy can we talk
about it
billy has no choice but to listen to
chef ramsay because if he won't listen
then we might as well just shut the
doors and walk away right now i have
never ever ever seen my kitchen fall
apart like that ever
ever on our busiest nights
never have i seen that ever
melissa has to talk now this is the most
crucial stage of the service where she
has to open up and and talk and get help
from there and get help it's just
delicate with so many tables on the man
is one of the top chefs in the world
and um maybe i should um put aside the
ill feelings and listen to what he has
to say melissa may not be communicating
but the menu is faster
i see what you're saying
at that point i was very open-minded to
his ideas seriously i'm pleased you're
back yeah hey you're the you're the
foundation of this place we have a
little chat with the staff because i
think they would like to hear that we're
all on the same track
the first hour of service was amazing
and then we got backed up we got backed
up bad
melissa you refused to communicate i
didn't know what the [ __ ] was going on
yeah i agree with you honestly this menu
has to come down yes that has to be
condensed it'd be appreciated new small
dynamic menu a menu that we can push out
it'll be real nice to get a new menu
that'll be more concise and in order
it'll be good
re-launch tomorrow night
we have to make it a success get some
sleep yes
in preparation for the relaunch
gordon's team worked through the night
updating handlebar's tired dated look
[Music]
ready
let's have a look at the new handlebar
let's go
oh wow
oh wow
oh my god it's gorgeous
this place looks awesome
it's
fresh
it's new billy it's warm there's nothing
that's antiquated
oh my god
wow
oh it's awesome
feeling wow wow is all i can say wow wow
wow
yeah wow what about the
more lamps we are no longer stuck in the
80s
look at it
warm bright vibrant happy yes
oh thank you everything is awesome it's
incredible i'm totally blown away
billy
you have long island's first ever
gastropub
[Music]
gastropub what the [ __ ] is a gastropub
what's a gastroparesis good question
good question
i've never heard of a gastro pub but
we're the first on long island that is
so incredibly awesome
our gastropub is warm open all hours
come and relax and enjoy with no
intimidation we cater for everybody it's
perfect for the neighborhood there are
25 gastro pubs in manhattan and they are
doing a phenomenal amount of business
a pub with an emphasis on fine food at
reasonable prices that kind of hit home
it was exactly the type of place that my
wife and myself were looking to turn it
into
knowing billy and carolyn's love for
motorcycle riding let's go ready to make
some noise yes gordon has organized
handlebars first annual motorcycle rally
to help spread the word about the
relaunch ecstatic
but what billy and carolyn don't know is
gordon has reached out to another bike
enthusiast
and rock and roll legend twisty's
sister's very own d snyder hey
good to see you
thank you so much for coming
[Music]
i never would have imagined here i would
get on my bike and ride with chef ramsey
and d snyder i was like oh my god how
cool is that billy
are you ready yes we are it was
phenomenal that gordon ramsay got him to
come here and help us kick off the new
start of the restaurant
[Music]
it was nice to get out there and ride
it's nice to see that chef ramsay could
ride a motorcycle and enjoy himself it
was a lot of fun
right let's go get these out
the grand reopening of handlebar tonight
contest to the handlebars reopening
tonight grand reopening come on down
come on down i'm smiling because i feel
that the handlebar is pointed in the
right direction now we have some place
to go and some place to look forward to
[Music]
now that the word had spread gordon gets
back to the crucial task of introducing
the new gastropub menu that's the menu
in front of it look at it there is
nothing complicated on there whether
it's the steak
mussels the salmon the sausage
everything is so
simply done
the new menu i think is uh phenomenal he
consolidated it down to a lot of the
comfort food type favorites just served
in a different light melissa this is the
night that we make the statement
and when we start getting in the weeds
you have to come out yourself and open
up yes sir
chef ramsay put his effort into this to
change us so we're gonna try not to let
him down we're gonna start confirming
the first ever gastropub in long island
after the bomb last night i'm sweating
i'm nervous to see how my kitchen pulls
it together make it work
[Music]
good evening
welcome thank you it's the grand
reopening of the handle bar nice to see
my daddy welcome welcome welcome and
chef ramsay's motorcycle rally has
clearly spread the word about the
relaunch enjoy your meal thank you let's
go let's go let's go with billy
appearing to embrace chef ramsay's
changes everything's homemade everything
all eyes are now on melissa to step it
up in the kitchen all right stay focused
here we go
everybody's excited to come in and see
how it looks now and see what's going on
with the menu and everything else can i
have the portobello mushroom melt
grilled chicken sandwich sound good you
all will be pleased with the food
tonight thank you
[Music]
melissa i need the shrimp cocktail and
then the salads and then the entrees
all right
melissa
melissa listen to me i want this
communication ramped up tonight you need
to connect the minute you stop talking
we're [ __ ] yeah
i think melissa needs to be more
assertive and keep everybody under
control let's go too quiet for me
as the restaurant fills up thank you
and customers embrace the new gastropub
venue
gordon takes a moment to make a special
announcement ladies and gentlemen please
welcome
a local legend twisty sisters yes dee
snyder yahoo
hey
[Applause]
came in through the door on that bike it
was just amazing everybody was clapping
and cheering and having a great time how
cool is this huh
all right here's the deal
in honor of the grand reopening of
handlebar restaurant we're going to be
auctioning this bike off so if you want
to bid on this beautiful holly davidson
sportster you can go to handlebar
restaurant website and put a bid in
there and all the proceeds will go to
the march of dimes
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
with d snyder's family and friends now
seated i'm going with a portobello
mushroom melt
in the first fully packed house in over
a year it's all about steak fish and
chips
the kitchen is about to be tested
the salmon looks black underneath
melissa
[Music]
i don't think it's burned honestly pass
through the spatula
i think it's okay
no way madam yeah
oh yeah
i'm not serving charcoal [ __ ] like that
[ __ ] disgusting
melissa thought she could just take care
of everything herself and she had two
other cooks and didn't ask for their
help he's a re-cook i'm very sorry beth
i hope it is better me too missy
so sorry
in her rush to fill orders freaking
salmon melissa starts sacrificing the
quality of the food this isn't good
look at the middle of the [ __ ]
salmon gross
that time it looked like what you'd find
in a seafood section like it was shiny
and a little cold like are you [ __ ]
kidding me the salmon we sent came back
[ __ ] raw so we're doing it again for
the third time
freaking salmon let's do this i think
melissa got very flustered back there
falling apart why are we falling apart
do we have any other salmon elsewhere
she is yeah where is my salmon when the
freaking salmon
billy if it's burnt or it's raw again
i'm gonna shove it down somebody's
throat everything just kept compounding
and compounding to the point where it
was a total disaster
[Music]
you gotta be kidding me
i'm gonna hang myself
i burnt the [ __ ] out of this
after first over cooking no [ __ ] way
then undercooking the salmon
melissa hopes the third time is the
charm
but she's got to open up and [ __ ]
communicate if she doesn't start
communicating now we're [ __ ] yeah
please yeah she needs to utilize the
other two cooks that she has in the
kitchen it's not a one-man show and it
could never work if she thinks it can be
honey let's just get it right this time
melissa use these two guys i'm trying i
want to hear it
open up communicate yeah
you know what you want to cook that i
know
please thank you
i will take care of the veg
good go i realized i can't take care of
the line on my own
salt and pepper please
i didn't really need to open up and
communicate and get things going your
salmon is coming honey i'm very sorry
lovely
you're the girl
thank you very much honey
gordon's persistence with melissa
appears to finally be paying off you
give it a thumbs up
all right we gotta get this together i
need three arb fries
right now at the moment i understand
chef ramsay's whole concept is to
communicate and keep everything in order
we've got to get it going as long as i
can communicate with the guys next to me
it will get it working properly i need
to concentrate on dee's table yes we are
doing it okay
take the two burgers whenever you can
melissa really shocked me tonight where
she was able to ask eric and george oh
can you do this can you get this we are
doing real well let's keep it up
very very good
this is amazing lovely that's good
tonight we had a couple of really large
screw-ups but in the end it all worked
out hey great venue right everybody was
happy i feel very excited i feel good
that's it
in the next couple of days the word
continued to spread throughout long
island about its first gastropub we have
a wonderful new menu that was the best
burger i've ever used i thought it would
cook really well reinvigorated by the
new direction and updated menu melissa
has found her passion again one small
caesar one small half chef ramsay being
here has definitely brought new life
into my job chicken sandwiches up and
out burgers up and out i do have more
passion about it i want to make sure
everything is good i'm surprising myself
now even the wait staff has taken it
upon themselves to maintain the
cleanliness of the restaurant we're
going to make a list of what needs to be
cleaned every night because we want to
keep it clean and we want to make it
look like
presentable and billy with renewed hope
and determination is moving forward some
to enjoy while they're waiting to take
your order inspiring everyone to make
the handlebar a success
well done
this place is going to be a success i
tell you great location
great food
great gastropub my wife and myself are
very appreciative when he did seemed
like there was a black cloud hanging
over the handlebar
um i think the sun's starting to shine a
little bit
congratulations on being long island's
first gastro club
okay good night
chef ramsay came to my restaurant went
above and beyond anything i could have
possibly asked for and i know this
restaurant's going to be successful from
here on out
that was tough very tough indeed we made
a lot of changes changed the menu
changed the decor but there was one
thing in there that i thought was
completely unchangeable
and that was bill
and we even managed that
[Music]